sur le mix électrique je crois qu'à ce
stade il
est le mix électrique ne sera pas
infin défini
par par simplement une définition exanté
de ce vers quoi nous devons nous devons
converger nous avons besoin d'un système
électrique qui fonctionne tout le
temps chacun des moyens de production a
ses propres caractéristiques
elles ont et tous les moyens de produ
son décarboné ont un intérêt ils ont une
un rôle à jouer dans ce système
électrique le système électrique doit
simplement être résilient en utilisant
la totalité de ces moyens de production
et donc nous devons être capable à
l'horizon 2035 2040 2050 d'avoir un
système électrique qui répond à la
demande de nos
concitoyens qui ne demande pas toujours
la même puissance électrique disponible
mais qui demande que lorsqu'ils ont
besoin de la puissance électrique elles
soit au rendez-vous face à ça nous avons
des moyens de production décarbonés
intermittents qui produisent quand les
éléments le décident c'est l'ensemble du
renouvelable nous avons des éléments
décarbonés commandables qui sont
l'électricité électronucléaire
électricité hydraulique nous avons même
dans l'hydraulique des capacités de
stockage que nous pouvons augmenter nous
aurons d'ici là une forme de
commandabilité associée à des formes de
stockage y compris probablement une
partie du véhicule électrique dont on
pourra déplacer la charge en fonction
des besoins mais nous avons nous avons
besoin de continuer de développer la
fleibilité de notre de notre dispositif
électrique pour qu'il soit résilient
face à de plus en plus d'instabilité
structurelle à la fois des consommations
et des productions et c'est ça Infiné
qui doit déterminer notre stratégie en
terme en terme de mix de production